we assume that everyone's going to cry
when we die but most of us won't even be
remembered for six months no one's
thinking about you the Queen of England
died eight or nine months ago now she
amassed more wealth than 99.99 of the
population she was a monarch for 70
years which has to be close to a record
she did it as a female which is even
more amazing and whoever's listening to
this probably hasn't thought about the
Queen of England we have all this
irrational fear around taking bigger
swings doing the things that we want to
do we play these videotapes in our minds
of these future scenarios where people
who aren't thinking about us are saying
things that they're not even thinking
because they don't care about you and
they think about themselves